[Music]
can i introduce you to something
have you seen um it's not from
california is it man because i can't
take this [ __ ] no no
well yes but it's it's not that it's
gonna make you mad so there's a student
named plastic patty and well i'll just
play this he makes these animations you
think you're the real people uh it's a
tales from the papa verse have you seen
these tales from the papa verse is
[ __ ] amazing
that's a very funny name
by the way i found this in the fighter
and the kid uh uh read it
i'm a good guy man
[Music]
and then i come home and he put sticky
notes
all over his entire food so what i do i
eat all of it and i throw out the rest
i'm ready to throw down right like that
i'm just gonna [ __ ] speed up my
phone's ringing like non-stop what the
[ __ ] i answer it it's his mom you gotta
pay it back you need to apologize
[ __ ] off hung up the phone
remember he's a good guy
brandon's a nice guy it's funny because
he these uh um well i'll keep playing
you talk to my mom like that
of course which is all i'm trying to do
i'm trying to fight this yeah i walk in
and i'm like bye man car so it's all i'm
trying to do i'm trying to fight this
guy
broke into because you want to be a
[ __ ] we're going to fight right now i'm
going to [ __ ] you up
so so this story remember the
animation's funny but this is a real
thing that this is they take it from his
pod
so
you
were eating another guy's food by the
way you didn't eat one triscuit no you
all that's he probably ate like
a whole box of triscuits one time right
and then the guy was like yo man i'm
gonna label my food like you know and
college kids are broke and then he took
that as [ __ ] you all eat all your [ __ ]
and i'll take everything from you and
beat your ass you [ __ ] yes he's a nice
guy he seems like a nice guy
he goes i'm not fighting you ace ventura
2 sago
hold on hold on
his point of reference for hawking
lugi was ace ventura 2 style yeah just
like that memorable
scene in ace ventura in base ventura 2.
fighting you ace ventura 2 sago he does
look like he just came out of a rhino's
[ __ ] though huh
whoo loogie right in his face
he's a good guy
he's face to face wow
oh my god look at the calendar animation
okay oh my god
again i'm going to post a link after
this don't worry he's doing these as
well plastic patty p-a-d-d-y plastic
patty
he does nothing
wow nice grab
threw him through our glass storage what
you threw a person through a glass door
over a food dispute so now you know none
of this is real no shout out
and you didn't go to jail and i went to
practice
and told me
bro this is [ __ ] great
this is really good
[ __ ] dude
i'm a good person i'm a great i'm a good
[ __ ] person man i'm a good diamond
i'm a good guy man
take it from me i'm too nice i take
advantage of all the time all the time
he gets taken advantage of all the time
that's why he threw somebody through a
glass door for triscuits you know this
all the time because i'm so nice
nice people don't say that brendan
can i say this the only way i want to
consume brendan's shop content now is
from from animation to this channel this
is so good this is so good we're back to
groceries and there's a kid with down
syndrome who was bagging him too i hated
my life and my job there so i'd grab all
the new magazines and candy and donuts
just sit in the bathroom crumple up the
magazines and then i put the magazine
back and finally got a meeting and they
were like hey whoever the [ __ ] is
ruining the mags and everything you know
this is a problem someone inside it's an
inside job doing this and i thought the
easy victim would be the kid with down
oh no
he blamed a child with down syndrome
because he was stealing magazines and
eating candy bars
papa
yeah i mean
to be honest what age is this though i
mean at least 16 17. let's just say
that's
i don't know man i mean i worked with a
[ __ ] guy at that age and i would
have never done that to him you know i
don't know it's not really it's not even
the story necessarily it's that he's
telling it like wow this funny wild
thing i did what i was yeah he said he's
not saying it like man that was pretty
[ __ ] up he's singing more like [ __ ]
that guy because like mullen has a
similar story from like regular high
school that he said like that he would
he used to go to the computer class and
he would stick magnets in the back of
the [ __ ] computers and the monitors
and [ __ ] and he would blame them
yeah but here's the question but he was
telling the story like what a piece of
[ __ ] he was but and nick mullen doesn't
regularly go around saying he's a good
guy what a good guy he is no that's true
he's very blessed he always says he's a
piece of [ __ ] that's i think that's more
the point with the brandon thing it's
like the president is like i'm a good
guy hey i bullied this [ __ ] kid he's
like by the way the [ __ ] teachers
knew it was me it was like
it's just sort of those things i'd be
like oh no [ __ ] [ __ ] kid probably
did
oh oh my god
what is pop and thickies
what's one thing everyone hates around
the world
the [ __ ] kid got fired
you said that my career was going to be
over that you were going to expose oh
they're doing the bobby lee thing me too
logan and all these people
and that i should get a lawyer
brandon has no
he's got no right to remove this concept
it's not his punishment there's an
absolutely awful comedian named brendan
schaub who is currently suing a small
youtuber then pixels were over jokes
they made about him my video on shop's
gringo poppy special received a content
id claim just he's using the
abusing the youtube dmca copyright
system to take down videos that are
making fun
yep
i'm not kidding you
i am being sued
by brendan job
but if you go personal i see you in the
street
go back go back go back go back
take down videos that are making fun of
him
i'm not kidding you
i am being sued
[Music]
wait a minute is that tom segura
is it
maybe it's either tom sagor or burke
chrysler or me did he rip off thick boy
oh you might be right
yeah that's your mom's house that's tom
segura tom segura
has been selling thick boy nation
hoodies
for years
and it's two c's boi thick boy nation
which i guess because you know thomas
igor is a chunky guy what and and it's
literally
probably something that tom segura threw
up
as like a yeah i was holding on a second
hold on a second tom segura has never
thrown anything up
go ahead i apologize but that's what
watch watch this enemy of him all right
and then he pushed him out
[Laughter]
if you go personal and i see you on the
streets there's going to be
repercussions you're going to hit me
personally because listen i have no
problem taking away your ferrari homeboy
i see you in the street
well there's gonna be repercussions it
was at a level 10 of rain
it was brian callan
[Music]
oh look at the tits look at the tits
good [ __ ] person oh this is awesome
bro this is
i will never i've always loved your work
i wanted to i'd stop and punch my car's
window because my dog died on my chest
because there's my service dog i guess
in the military and you played that and
you guys were actually making light of
it but i'm but i'm sorry if that caused
you to turn off the show
we don't need you
this isn't a show for you sounds good
you're finally going after anyone who
harasses you online including comics
you have spent half a million dollars on
monster lawyers and that you have
friends in dark places who are going to
get the job done
this is really well done there's no
crime
yeah this isn't i'm just saying is that
nice is that nice
you know what the best part about this
is
hey brendan
copy strike this yeah go ahead now this
is transformative this is beyond
transformative yeah
do you respect brendan shaw
[Music]
[Applause]
i know skanks had calen on yesterday
doing the lie detector
[Music]
whoever drew these if so well by the way
the guy that drew whoever drew the
brennan child but going
what the [ __ ] that is the best one
[Applause]
wow this is really well made sick boy
cyber security division
wearing a [ __ ] dress i i know he's
triangulating the signal of the haters i
hate you i
the net 3.0 starring mark harley i mark
out no pun intended every time big gay
lion comes on
using an rx modulator i might be able to
conduct a mainframe cell directly up
into the downloads
he's going to the matrix guys he's going
in look at his little legs
oh this guy is amazing
oh [ __ ] man this is this is an insane
ride i posted a link in the chat and
it's goatsi
he look look at the goat see
nice
[Music]
penetration complete
hold on hold on retrieving full reddit
user email database
triangulating gps coordinates
this is so [ __ ] good
i'll have the link in the description
guys we made another one
to save for another episode oh
absolutely dude i'll never need an
excuse for these so good
this guy does a very good job of drawing
these people i love this this is what's
interesting explain this however you
want
when i notified you guys of dude
oh yeah
that's great oh oh it's uh it's the mma
interviewer
what's his face helwani ariel hello
yeah bobby lee and
joe rogan
going back andrew schulzberg chrysler in
the back the tiger belly that luis j
gomez
stop posting
took the tiger belly email off and
changed it it's never posted again do
you know how reddit works
no
[Laughter]
the pause made it
please
pause like that again yes of course
of course i play this the little shrug
you can see his eyes look away
explain this however you want
when i notified you guys of the
harassment and going back to tiger belly
that account stopped posting
took the tiger belly email off and
changed it it's never posted again do
you know how reddit works
no
this is god tear [ __ ] right guys
dress like batman here's my thing i i
for me to really enjoy something you
know the problem is like a lot of people
make something and they get like too
attached it's like a lot of the brendan
people become too like
spiteful and [ __ ] and people don't add
enough stupidness to these things to
make it like like this is the perfect
talent
work that went into it and it's a little
petty but it's not like this [ __ ]
like this is just made to be silly
and stupid and it's very good and this
makes brendan look worse than any of the
hate stuff like this is way better
because it's so silly in it it just
relegates all these people to such a
stupid level
[Music]
great job
director dishwasher number two syracuse
new york producer bartender number four
newport beach california writers george
carlton lewis casey patrice o'neil
i love how everybody involved in this
project is from a pf changs
this is beyond good
i i subbed it's plastic daddy on uh
beyond well beyond well patty
a plastic patio and uh
check check show links lean and mean
made something for us if it's not as
good as this i don't want to see it
i mean it's it's derivative
okay fair enough
uh
show oh this oh yes i like it
pull it up for everybody hold on
there you go
that really is [ __ ] that canon was so
funny man
very well done they were extra mean
of all to gallon
i love how they have him i love how
little miami was sitting with his legs
up